[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
guess who's back guess who's back guess
who's back that's right we're back on
YouTube [ __ ]
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
seven day suspension seven day ban
is ended has ended it's come to an end
and no more perfect time than today no
more perfect time than today
let we get back on YouTube and the
reason why is because
Republicans release their commitment to
Cruelty today they caught the commitment
to America this is the same thing where
they project to make America great again
[ __ ]
literally if you go line by line through
what they want to do their plan
because they say Democrats don't have a
plan we have a plan they have a plan to
destroy America that is their plan
that's been their plan the whole time
it's always been their plan they want to
destroy democracy because it doesn't
serve them anymore
it does not serve them they want to
oppress the rights of other people and
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ]
and that is exactly the freedom that
they're talking about today in their
plan for cruelty for America their
commitment to Cruelty to America is to
oppressed
the rights of other people
that's it it's what it is
I'm glad I'm back on YouTube now a lot
of people on YouTube weren't aware
exactly what happened a lot of people
were messaging and I was trying to get
the message across hey go to Tony
Michaels dot live
and I want to tell everyone out there
watching on YouTube right now make sure
you bookmark tonymichaels.live you can
watch us over there you can watch us on
Twitch as well you can go to Facebook if
you're on Facebook if you have a
Facebook account you can follow me on
Facebook I'm broadcasting there now too
we're gonna try to broadcast everywhere
we even open up a Discord if you're on
Discord I encourage you to go find the
Tony Michaels podcast on Discord
so you can go follow us there we plan on
broadcasting there as soon as we figure
it out we were gonna try to get through
the whole uh YouTube band
it just so happened to during the week
that I YouTube man I I rearranged my
studio here too so it's a little
different scenery behind me if you
notice
but I have not been in I have not gone
anywhere all those episodes that weren't
able to go live on YouTube I put them up
on YouTube over last night
so if you didn't get a chance to watch
them on Twitch uh Twitter uh Facebook
you can now go to YouTube and they're
all in the full episodes playlist so you
can watch all those episodes that were
missed but I'm happy to have you back
here and I want to tell you I want to
tell you guys that the support that you
guys showed through our band has been
tremendous I can't I I was I was really
I was frustrated when they banned me and
I appealed they knocked down RPO I
thought we would win the appeal uh just
because it was a video that was a year
old
that they actually knocked us on they
gave us the suspension on I'm sure some
some troll reported it but what it was
in the video is I was mocking these
domestic terrorists that were going to
the school board meetings spreading all
this misinformation I was mocking them
and I guess because I had their video on
I don't I'm not really sure I could I
can't figure out why they wouldn't
um put get our YouTube account back
because I wasn't spreading this
information
I was trying to say that they were by
mocking them so they took down that
video
and that's what they knocked us on they
gave us a strike on that but I did win
an appeal I will tell you the good news
is I did appeal again to a the warning
that I had so as soon as our strike
period is over which is sometime in
December
um then we won't have a warning or a
strike so it'll be less likely that
we'll get banned for seven days on
YouTube
but I am so happy that you're here I'm
happy to be here spread the word around
that we are back on YouTube but not only
are we on YouTube we are on Facebook we
are on Twitch we are on Twitter you can
go to Tony Michaels dot live and you can
watch live there at our website we are
now broadcasting live from our own
website tonymichaels dot live go support
Independent Media there as well
me and Gabe work hard every single day
to bring you exactly what you need to
know what's going on in the world and
how to politicize it
that's right I said it
how to politicize the issues because it
is important it is super important that
we play politics folks because this
morning the Republicans boy they're
really leaning into taking away people's
freedom and making sure domestic
terrorists aren't on watch list are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me I'm not kidding you
Kevin McCarthy says if you're a domestic
terrorist we will take you off the watch
list that's what the Republicans
platform
that's their commitment to America is to
take domestic terrorists off watch list
I'm not [ __ ] you
that's their commitment so what are you
gonna do are you gonna sit back and let
them take away our democracy
steal our democracy investigate Hunter
Biden's laptop and and who what this Roy
Epps the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] Jamie ranskin
had a great just I mean he absolutely
dumped uh Thomas Massey and these
Republicans in the house in the trash
yesterday when they started talking
about Roy X I guess Hunter Biden's
laptops got to take a vacation every now
and again
I can't even believe that this Roy at
this Roy Epps thing this guy
who who clearly had been delusional by
the internet was just saying everything
the internet was telling him he was
singing in the streets at their rally at
their rally
weeks before not not not that day he
wasn't even there
and they act like that some kind of
conspiracy theory these [ __ ] people I
tell you what there's calling Stacy
Abrams a conspiracy theorist for talking
about science how there is no real
heartbeat at six weeks dummies that's an
electrical impulse that is picked up by
an ultrasound machine there is no
developed heart there you dumb
[ __ ] and they think she's some
kind of community conspiracy theorist
when Roy Epps is their Hail Mary pass
holy [ __ ]
their commitment to America is cruelty
they want to take away your freedom they
want to take away your [ __ ] rights
and they're hell-bent on it National
Abortion ban they want to take away
Social Security Medicare Medicaid they
want to strip it from you
the America that you know they hate
they [ __ ] hate the America that you
know
and they hate they hate the America that
democracy will deliver this country they
[ __ ] hate it
because they're bigots
they're fascist
and they're absolutely 100 percent
trumpist
full-on full stop
now I understand what they're trying to
do here with this commitment to America
but they're trying to pull a Newt
Gingrich that he pulled in the early 90s
it ain't gonna work we already know who
they are
we already know who they are they've
already called themselves domestic
terrorists
in Texas at one of their Nazi rallies
they literally said we are all domestic
terrorists right yeah yeah we sure are
and now their commitment to Cruelty on
America is to make sure that all those
domestic terrorists that they
self-proclaim they are are off watch
list
while the Cheeto dust mobster threatens
violence and Stokes terrorism
on social media on his fraud Social
account with Q Anon they have Nazi
rallies where they're given a one-finger
Nazi salute to the Cheeto dust mobster
the orange Jesus
come on give me a [ __ ] break here
Contra get commitment to America it's a
commitment to America to turn it into a
fascist State that's their commitment
so steadfast you got to stay in you
gotta lean into this thing
I'm telling you we got to politicize
every single measure of this commitment
to America we can't ignore it you gotta
pick it apart and tear it apart and go
after it and smash it up with a [ __ ]
hammer
politics is a [ __ ] but if you
want if you want democracy
and you want to govern and you want
certain policies in this country you got
to play politics
Jamie Raskin knows that holy [ __ ] you
talk about a video clip I got to show
you from yesterday there's a ton of
video to show you the problem is we have
bone end of the week it's Friday
it's Friday and we have bone end of the
week
but I got a lot of video to show you so
we're gonna have to do like lightning
round shitless Roundup today boom boom
boom boom boom first day back
off the YouTube band
and we got a ton of video a great
shitless Roundup that is gonna happen I
know that
and then we have the bone end of the
week
which
I think I know who won
[Laughter]
oh my God
hell the Cheeto dust mobster I believe
um was in the was in the front running a
bonehead of the week for his little I
thinketh and now Chef shelf be it
the Presidential Power extends to ESP
this is really [ __ ] dumb really
[ __ ] bone-headed
but it's no wonder it's no wonder that
the Republicans right before the midterm
have to throw a Hail Mary pass blame Roy
Epps and then release their contract of
Cruelty on America
when they're saying hey look we are
going to enforce the law on brown people
and black people but white people we're
not going to enforce the law matter of
fact we're going to investigate the
people who are investigating white
people
it's literally what they're saying I'm
not [ __ ] you now you're not gonna
see the whole thing because you're not
gonna watch that [ __ ] no one was
watching it on Twitter
I mean literally I went over to the
Kevin McCarthy's page leader McCarthy
was broadcasting that [ __ ] live on
Twitter
now now remember leader McCarthy has 1.3
million followers on Twitter and he was
Broadcasting
the commitment to America
on Twitter I've got I don't know I've
got 30 some thousand followers on
Twitter
and we get 100 200 at a time watch it on
Twitter sometimes it's three four ten
thousand fifteen thousand our numbers
vary on Twitter Twitter is a little
weird on the broadcast numbers I don't
think it's very consistent I don't think
it's very accurate either but here's the
thing
the live broadcast numbers are pretty
pretty spot on of how many are watching
at once
and I took a screenshot there was only a
couple hundred folks watching at one
time on Twitter the the commitment to
cruelty that Kevin McCartney Kevin
McCarthy was laying out for America
he was he was he was laying out the
freedom for white people to oppress the
rights of other people is what he was
doing
he's laying it out white supremacy and
all baby
trumpism goddamn right
taking away your [ __ ] schools I've
been saying they're gonna take away your
[ __ ] schools
but he only had a few hundred people
watching it once and my guess is
my guess is that the majority of those
few hundred people were watching it to
pick it apart
and doing what we're doing here
watching it so you don't have to
I'm sure that's what it was
they they just they don't have the grasp
on messaging right now because they've
shown their cards they've shown America
who they are
and America is concerned about democracy
yeah do we have do we have issues about
health care and and the economy and
wages yeah but you can't solve all those
problems if you let these people destroy
our democracy how are you going to have
any kind of voice
if you Lut the the Maga Republicans the
America First Nazis take over our
country and take away all your Liberty
how in the [ __ ]
how in the [ __ ]
are you gonna have any say
about how you want to fix the problems
that we actually have the [ __ ] we need
to get done
like
a
having a decent [ __ ] wage not going
broke because of a medical bill making
sure your kids start school at three
instead of five making sure that your
kids aren't saddled with
hundreds of thousands of dollars worth
of debt because they need an education
to make it in this economy
this is important stuff with liberty and
they want to take it away from you they
don't want public education they want to
take that away
they want to abolish the Department of
Education
abolish it get rid of it you don't have
that Liberty anymore not a liberty you
have
I'm dead serious
they want to take away your education
system the whole thing
they want to take away student loans
they don't want you to go to college
anymore they hate colleges that colleges
spread around the truth oh they they
open your mind to ideas like equality
and equity you start to you know see the
the greatness of diversity in this
country and it starts to Cloud your mind
with equality and Equity by God we need
bigots and we need them now that's their
attitude they don't like colleges they
don't want to pay for it
they definitely don't want to educate
your little children for sure they don't
want them they don't want them to read
[ __ ] books by God they're banning
Book Fairs down in Florida
matter of fact in Tennessee they want to
marry the children I mean they're not
going to be in school anymore there's
not going to be Department of Education
why not in Tennessee that's what they
want
they're in big trouble folks and if you
don't know how big a trouble they're in
just go this morning and look at your
[ __ ] comments look at the thread
comments of the [ __ ] that they're
talking about they're terrified
they're using Roy apps
as their Hail Mary pass
of why Republican members of Congress
Donald Trump and his criminal [ __ ]
lawyers and his criminal [ __ ] allies
like Mike Lindell Mike Flynn Sydney
Powell
John Eastman Christina Bob Judy Giuliani
Steve Bannon tried to help him steal the
election they're trying to [ __ ]
divert your attention with Roy Epps look
at this guy who showed up at one of
their rallies who is one of their
supporters who was saying [ __ ] that
they're saying now
they're saying it now
Donald Trump is on social media
disseminating all kinds of Q Anon [ __ ]
not even hiding it anymore he's not even
typing in code folks he's not even
talking in code anymore he's outright
saying I have a Q Anon cult I'm the
[ __ ] leader and I'm gonna make sure
that these people are angry mad and they
want to commit violence he doesn't want
to participate in democracy they don't
want to do democracy
they'll lose they know they'll lose when
they do democracy if you indict me my
supporters will kill people that's what
he's saying not so many words but that
is what he's saying he said it to Hugh
Hewitt he said it to Sean Hannity
there's going to be trouble it's going
to be bad they're gonna pay the price if
they indict me if they punish me for the
crimes that I committed
[ __ ] out of here with that nonsense
they're terrified of democracy they're
terrified of it and that's the best
thing for us folks because all we got to
do is lean into that [ __ ] just [ __ ]
lean into democracy really give it our
all engage
make sure to check your registration
make sure you tell your family and your
friends to check the registration get
people registered go knock some doors if
that's what you're good at Hell make
some phone call text messages find those
candidates that you can support if you
can send them five dollars ten dollars
fifty a hundred send it to them they're
gonna need it
because the gqp they're they're boosting
candidates they're boosting candidates
they're getting rid of them they're
they're cutting their losses because
they're out of money folks they're out
of money because the cultists are all
giving it to their orange deity and he
ain't doing a [ __ ] thing for them
he's dragging them down with his fascism
his calls for violence and his Q Anon
Nazi cult
it's beautiful we got him on the Run we
got him in the corner
don't lose sight of what is important
which is your way of life your democracy
and you have to engage in it you must
that's the only way to keep democracy
you're not going to keep democracy
without leaning into it you're not going
to keep your your Liberty without
democracy if you put these people in
power no matter where it is all the way
down to the goddamn dog catcher Governor
legislator county commissioner
it is important
that you show this country
that trumpism is not what we are this is
not what we are this is hatred this is
bigotry this is fascism and it's not
what we do it's not how we operate here
in the United States of America the
United States of America
we want democracy
we want equality and equity and yeah
we're gonna have to make some [ __ ]
compromises that's how it works
democracy is hard democracy is tough
that's why liberals aren't lazy this
idea that Liberals are lazy is [ __ ]
stupid
Liberals are the only ones that are
willing to work to set good policy
Republicans are like hey we'll just let
domestic terrorists run rampant we'll
get them off watch list and we'll let
you we'll let you go out and commit all
kinds of domestic terrorist acts that's
literally what they're saying this
morning
literally what they're saying this
morning is they want to get rid they
want to get rid of this idea that we're
going to make sure our IRS has enough
[ __ ] agents to operate the agency
that [ __ ] taxes people this is really
stupid they want to get rid of IRS
agents so they're rich [ __ ] donors
don't have people bothering them about
the taxes they're trying to cheat on us
the American people
but they want to enforce the law their
law enforcement law in order
we're gonna lock up them criminals they
mean brown people that's what they mean
brown and black people that's what
they're saying that's dog whistle We're
Not Gonna lock you white domestic
terrorist step we're gonna let you run
free hell we want you to go commit
domestic terrorism hell we'll even we'll
even put it on a banner in Texas and
call ourselves domestic terrorists but
those criminals those long break law
Breakers
they mean black and brown people that's
what they mean
doubt me on this you can [ __ ] doubt
me all you want I'm telling you and I
know how these people talk in code I
know it if you don't think I know it
just look at me just listen to how I
sound look where I'm from I know what
the [ __ ] they're saying
they're saying we're gonna let white
terrorists white criminals white like
Donald Trump run run all over the
country Steve Bannon Rudy Giuliani
Michael Flynn the lot of them John
Eastman we're gonna let them all off
because they committed crime for white
supremacy they committed crime for
fascism their their our domestic
terrorism we're going to let them go
but all all inner city black brown
people Urban people liberals we're gonna
go get them
we're gonna go get them and we're gonna
enforce them Laos we're gonna lock them
criminals up that's what they're saying
folks
listen to them when they're telling you
what they're gonna do
okay
listen to him Jesus Christ you got Greg
Abbott and Ron DeSantis trafficking
trafficking human beings
all over the country
all over the criminally probably I mean
they're just criminal investigations now
there's probably going to be indictments
because they're it looks like they're
not just breaking state laws but Federal
human trafficking laws Jesus Christ the
coercing these people on planes and
buses
whew
trying to get him to go to areas where
they have no idea where they're going
which you know the funny part about it
is those areas would welcome those folks
if Greg Abbott and Ron DeSantis just
plucked their head out of their ass and
and got with got with liberal blue areas
and blue States and organized with them
to get those people to those places
those places would welcome them people
they'd be like yes please come here
please come here we actually have a
labor shortage in this country it's a
problem and we know that migrants are
more excited about working in this
country than any other [ __ ]
demographic because that's why they come
here they come here for the American
dream
and the American dream is not to sit
around eating Cheetos [ __ ] watching
orange Mussolini Jesus talk his [ __ ]
that's not the American dream the
American dream is to work hard provide
for your family provide a better life
for your family that's the American
dream and they know it
that's why Greg Abbott and Ron DeSantis
don't want them there
they don't want to give a leg up to
migrants Jesus Christ I mean unless
they're you know white
these aren't White migrants
and these people are refugees most of
these people that they're demonizing are
people here seeking Asylum they're not
here illegally they're here legally
under the guise of asylum
uh here we go
see this is is Gabe gay this gay big gay
beer on Facebook he keeps talking about
my student loan hey fake game let me
tell you something I'm a two-time
College Dropout
okay I'm a two-time College Dropout and
I had a lot of [ __ ] student loans and
I'd have a degree I don't have a degree
to back it up
all it is is my my brains my smarts
because my education was in the
education of Hard Knocks
which most Americans are they work hard
even college educated with degrees are
in the School of Hard Knocks
but I paid off my student loans
[ __ ] years ago years ago paid
them off so good luck with that good
luck with your little your little
liberal narrative there oh look at this
little libtard he must he must got he
must got a paycheck a welfare check from
the government it's not a welfare check
from the government dummy
to see this the [ __ ] I'm talking about
this is the [ __ ] I'm talking about fake
game here is worried about people
getting a leg up
in the economy
getting a head start because the
government charged them all kinds of
[ __ ] interest on their federal
subsidized student loans did you know
fake Gabe that the ten thousand dollars
most people are going to receive isn't
even gonna cover the interest that they
paid over the life of the loan you dumb
[ __ ]
the government you the government made
all kinds of money they taxed people
dummy to get student loans are you
listening to what the [ __ ] I'm saying
dummy they taxed [ __ ]
a high percentage rate on the loans that
they gave him to get college to get that
degree so they can make it in the world
you're a dumb son of a [ __ ] you're a
dumb [ __ ] and I hope you stay
here I hope you learn and by the time
we're done with this oh man you'll be so
[ __ ] smart you'll be one of the
libtards Just Like Us Gabe Gabe you will
be one of the libtards Just Like Us hell
you may even get you a George Soros
check one of these days
oh my God oh my God we got a lot of [ __ ]
to get to today in the shitless Roundup
uh and we got bonehead of the week as
well I'm super excited about being back
on YouTube super [ __ ] excited
super super super
excited to be back on YouTube I'm glad
all of you stuck with us what a great
audience
um you guys really are
I want to tell you yeah I've been
hitting my desk I hit the desk this is
my new desk by the way in my new setup I
had to change it I got a longer desk now
trying to get more of a command center
going here so we can do more work
for our democracy so I kind of had to
change positions in the studio so it
looks a little different you can now see
my TV behind me here
and I had to move my my nugs not drugged
sign there it is and some of the other
shelves and stuff to make it all fit but
we are
we are down to work work for our
democracy I'm leaning into this [ __ ]
folks I'm not going anywhere I know it
felt like it some people like oh my god
what happened to your show I was like
look the show's still going go to Tony
Michaels dot Live support Independent
Media there support our show at Tony
Michaels dot live and I want to thank
everyone who's given
just just even the little amounts
of support but more than anything I mean
the ma the the Mona the monetary gifts
that you guys give to keep us going
means a lot and boy it does keep
Independent Media going because there's
no like there's no big huge thing that
people pay us big contracts to come and
talk right
I mean we're working on getting some
sponsorships here uh we we've we've done
our research on several sponsors that we
want to have we want to bring you guys
good sponsors that you guys can benefit
from we don't want to just have crazy
sponsors and just start doing ads and
charging them and then you guys not
really benefit from their products we
really want you to benefit from their
products if we have sponsors here so
we're looking we're we're working
hopefully next month we'll have some
sponsors that you guys can help support
sponsors and they can help support us
but the way you can support us and
support Independent Media in general
is is is tip them and you can go to
tonymichaels.live you can watch the show
live there you can still watch it on
Facebook YouTube twitch
but if you go to Tony Michaels dot live
you can give us a tip
you can give us a tip one time tip or
you can do a monthly tip where it's
automatic you know whatever amount that
you'd want and it's all
it's all appreciated because it keeps us
going here Keeps the Lights On keeps the
microphone on
but here's what I want to tell you I
really appreciate the monetary support
but more than anything just the support
you guys showed in chats the last few
days the guy how you guys downloaded
other apps just to watch this show
um is really encouraging I know we're on
the right track and I know we're going
to build a giant audience and I know you
guys are going to be the the very first
in to the this very large audience that
we're gonna build here at D Tony
Michaels podcast because as folks I've
said this time and time again this is
the most important election of our
lifetime and we're going to lean into
democracy and as soon as it's over as
soon as the the votes are counted and
certified the next one will be the most
important and I'm gonna lean into that
son of a [ __ ] every single day every
single day I'm gonna lean into it I'm
not gonna stop it's just not going
to happen and I appreciate all of you
all of your support the likes the shares
the retweets the comments on YouTube
while we were gone the comments on
Facebook the private messages the DMS
that were sent I want to tell all of you
that I love you and I love that you're
here and I love that you you love the
show
and we're we're not going to stop the
show and if and if if for some reason
you find the show comes off the platform
that's why you need to bookmark Tony
Michaels dot live
that's our website they can't take us
down from that website tonymichaels dot
live
go there bookmark the website watch
there every once in a while if you want
hell again you there's a tip jar right
there next to the live broadcaster right
underneath the live broadcast depending
on if you're watching on a computer or
mobile and you can tip us one time or
you can tip us each month however you
want to set it up we appreciate all the
support that you guys give us the other
thing that you can do is you can go to
our merch store
and give us support you guys have been
oh my God this merch is flying off the
shelves let me show you some of it
here's the doubt me merch and get
stickers
t-shirts hoodies coffee mugs doubt me
doubt me
and then there's the uh Rhonda Sanders
can go [ __ ] himself uh very very popular
set of merch
Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ] himself just
go to store.d Tony michaels.com again to
get the Tony Michaels podcast merch and
the the very favorite of everyone is the
dark Brandon design that we have the
exclusive the exclusive dark branded
design that we have
um so go to go to
store.dtonymichaels.com and find your
merch there dark Brandon merch you can
also go to tonymichaelslive.com and you
can hit the sandwich icon
and you can find all the links where you
want to go follow us they're all there
on tonymichaels.live and you can go to
the merch store uh if you want faka mats
I was wearing a [ __ ] hat yesterday
you can see it right there now just go
to
hats.d20michaels.com or go to
tonymichaels.live click the sandwich
icon the hats are right there the [ __ ]
them hats if you want to [ __ ] them man a
lot of people love the [ __ ] hats
I really appreciate all the support you
guys are wonderful I love all of you
even even the haters I love you too I
love that you show up every day we've
got some loyal hate Watchers here at the
Tony Michaels podcast we've had since
the very beginning there's Chris in
there's fake Gabe over on Facebook these
people these people come and they hate
watch and we love that they're here it's
it's very very very
very very reassuring that you people
follow this around the internet as we
dealt with this this YouTube man
and at just what Amanda says you're
spread toning like super gonorrhea
that's right
spread it around my purpose
spread it around like herpes thank you
very much everyone I really appreciate
you sticking with us for this week we
got a shitless Roundup coming and we
have bone end of the week because it is
Friday [ __ ] it's Friday a
temporary ban when we did we're able to
build our infrastructure to say hey
actually yeah oh yeah go over here yeah
because a lot of people went over to
Twitch
right and it's just YouTube that's the
problem but other places no problem yeah
well it happens so if this episode
doesn't actually go through
um on YouTube I'll just load it in like
I did the other ones because I did that
and a bunch of people went and got
caught up game oh nice and loaded all
the the episodes overnight that were
missed on YouTube because they wouldn't
let us Post we were banned so I so I I
loaded them in yeah they had a backhoe
at all of course you know I wanted to
make sure all the full episodes were
there the ones that they won't ban I
actually have a clip here that I want to
show yeah
and you know what [ __ ] it I can't
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] him
here is here's the uh here's part of
this commitment to Cruelty on America
this is a lady oh my God she is so
excited she's a domestic terrorist she
admits well I mean yeah well I mean you
know they all are the best tears but she
admits it she is and then she says some
crazy ass to Mexico terrorist q9 type
[ __ ]
it's something else of course we were we
this is the reason why we were kicked
off YouTube is because I was mocking
people who are spreading misinformation
but here I feel like I think I think Hal
has like a big satire like graphic that
comes up yeah like I know that obviously
it's like okay we're really gonna nail
this one on the head
but it is one of those things where you
know so maybe maybe what we should say
is just I mean we could come up with a
graphic or we could just say satire
incoming that way it's on the transcript
yeah right it's on the transcript right
right because YouTube has they even
though we if we don't submit a
transcript they still make their own
trading go through and they can actually
read it out you know right they get
their their little bot or whatever the
hell it's called I don't know it's like
a
you know it's a very successful video
streaming company that's owned by uh
Google I'm pretty sure they could figure
this out yeah they can figure this out
so so if if Google's um transcription
tool is listening this when we do this
here we're going to be mocking the
misinformation we're not actually
spreading around right we're trying to
disseminate and get rid of the
misinformation by showing you what it is
because sunlight is the best
disinfectant watch this dead domestic
terrorist at work and boy this audience
loves this domestic terrorist watch
now we have SEL which is social
emotional learning
it's indoctrination disguised as promo
programs like kindness initiatives or
anti-bullying programs or diversity
projects
these are all marks of style programs
targeting our children
then to make it all better the current
Administration weaponized the Department
of Justice
and all the parents speaking up at
school board meetings or challenging any
of these programs like I was was now
labeled a domestic terrorist
our department of justice is calling me
a mom
a domestic terrorist
so I have three questions maybe she
should look inward a bit I mean here's
the thing because your mom doesn't make
you
uh you know free right if you commit a
crime and you support terrorism you were
at the Insurrection whatever her
whatever whatever her actual like
involvement is what she's referring to
if you don't want to be called that then
don't do that right very simple just
like if you don't want to be charged
with Espionage probably don't steal top
secret classified diet yes probably not
a thing you want to do it's I mean
you'll be like hey that's a novel
thought it's not just don't commit the
crime like I don't understand now what
she's talking about here I think I think
specifically is that she was threatening
school board members because that's what
the doj was actually doing when when
these domestic terrorists were
threatening public officials which is
not a thing that you can do it is a
federal offense to threaten a public
official speech right you're threatening
them they were threatening them and and
it doesn't matter if it's a if it's a
federal office if it's a local office
doesn't matter
especially if you're threatening them
because they're in their official
capacity that's why the doj was crawling
in your ass lady is because you were
again a domestic terrorist and you you
guys love this label I don't know why
she's so so coy about this I mean they
put it up at CPAC they're like we are
domestic terrorists right it's like
almost like we are farmers
we are domestic terrorists
hey we should make a video listen this
is the thing if you listen to the first
part of this video though did you notice
how they're rebranding CRT did you see
that did you hear that s-e-l so social
emotional learning right they say is
anti-white anti-christian anti-American
what the [ __ ] what the hell she's like
programs like kindness and anti-bullying
oh my God oh my God you gotta be [ __ ]
[ __ ] me this is the new Marxism is
people being kind and not bullying each
other you people are out of your [ __ ]
well here's the thing is that these
people want bullying that's what they
want they don't want kindness they want
cruelty they're telling you they're
saying it out loud they're telling you
into a microphone
by the way like she's got a microphone
in her hand saying hey we want people to
be cruel to each other that's the
tenement of trumpism yeah I mean why not
it's [ __ ] ridiculous and and honestly
this is why we have to stay visually
years because Kevin McCarthy wants to
take these domestic terrorists off right
the death domestic terrorist list for
people who don't know what uh social
emotional learning is
it's something that we
yeah
it's so dumb because it's stuff that
we've already had in our classrooms for
years wait wait wait you are you saying
this isn't a new Marxist conspiracy this
is not new the only reason it was given
a new implementation was because in in
places like Minnesota they implemented
this after covid so keep in mind
students were at home they weren't able
to interact with those students in
person they weren't able to develop
those social skills they weren't able to
get that in-person collaboration
teaching from the the the
um the Head of the Class which is the
teacher right they weren't able to
develop these skills
um and it's not new what what they're
what they are teaching kids kids is to
manage their emotions develop positive
relationships and make good decisions
all of the things that you experience in
a classroom right
not only that but they're focused on
things like respect empathy gratitude
kindness honesty okay okay that's a
that's enough of your Marxist [ __ ] there
I'm look I'm trying to spread the
propaganda isn't it isn't it just
ridiculous that that kindness and
anti-bullying they're like immediately
like Oh you mean we can't call people
names you mean we can't denigrate
children you mean you mean we can't
bully people this is ridiculous you
Marxist right Liberal Liberal so keep in
mind SEL these programs have already
been in existence for decades it's
almost like the whole CRT CRT thing
where CRT has existed for decades it
wasn't what they said it is it's almost
like they're rebranding because they
can't say CRT because people like you're
[ __ ] nuts I mean so even in in my
small town in my small town
the school district they had a school
board election right they they always do
and there was a bunch of guys a dudes
white dudes trumped up [ __ ] white
dudes that were running for school board
and their main tenement was no CRT I'm
not [ __ ] like the signs their signs
was like elect white dude no CRT like
literally that's what it said
none of them won none of them the ones
who won were um women who were concerned
about I don't know education oh even
even in a very trumpy area that I live
in these people didn't win because
everyone knew it was nonsense that the
CRT was [ __ ] like if you had any
kind of Common Sense and especially if
you didn't pay attention to Trump
politics and politics in general you
were like CRT what the [ __ ] are you
crazy people yapping about and really
honestly most people were really pissed
off about these school board meetings
where parents who never [ __ ] had
anything to do with the school or lived
in another [ __ ] town were coming to
these school board meetings and crashing
these official meetings about their
children's education over some dumb ass
[ __ ] or some stupid [ __ ] lie because
they and and this is the reason why our
video got banned we got clipped on this
that's why we lost the and it's we're
breaking into those seven day band
because of this video but you know
whatever I guess whatever [ __ ] him uh
just go to Tony Michaels dot live in
case we we get cut off here no
um I I guess YouTube's back up now
everyone's saying and I checked it okay
seems like the feed so they got their
live they're live streaming back going
so um if you're if you're over if you
want to come back over to YouTube you
can try it
um but you know just stay where you're
at and come over to YouTube uh for the
bonehead of the week because we're we're
about to get into that we need to get in
there we got a lot of bone-headed [ __ ]
to get into and we're past this second
hour there's a lot of [ __ ] there's a lot
of stuff yeah I got a special uh Alpha
cut for you oh do you really yeah there
was actually there was there was stuff
Ronnie Jackson came into the news this
morning but he did not make the cut from
someone else that I felt needed a little
bit more attention oh really someone's
getting cucked I have a feeling this is
a story no one's been paying attention
to because of uh orange Jesus's thoughts
and he's related not by Blood though but
there's a lot to the story oh that
people might just see him as like a
one-time oh he was he was this person
but actually there's a history to him
and his involvement or his love affair
well let's do this let's go to a break
when we come back we'll go to bonehead
of the week everyone stick around don't
go anywhere don't go anywhere stay right
here if you're on YouTube and it's
working stay right here if you're on
Twitch Facebook don't go anywhere
bonehead of the week right after this
break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[Music]
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
I'm about to get into bone end of the
week
almost forgot to upload the graphics I'm
not [ __ ] you and Gabe worked hard on
these I'm getting them I'm getting in
there I'm getting there bone it up the
week
we're here we're here it's Friday second
hour bone end of the week
um yeah I gotta load it on these uh
Graphics yeah well so you got a big so
you got a big surprise here yeah
yeah I mean there were a lot of people
but I figured this guy yeah what he's
doing okay and and where he has been
recently I think it's really important
to call attention it came out yesterday
didn't see a lot of people really
talking about it at least that I saw at
the moment
um because
like every week there's always a [ __ ]
show that involves Trump right
um he is he is he is the epitome of [ __ ]
show yeah I mean like I wonder that was
actually one thing I wanted to point out
yesterday when we were on the show is
like that saggy bottom ass he had going
on in his seat let's do that let's do
that today well let's get into it let's
start bone end of the week start that
music
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bone end of
the week we have a great bonehead of the
week for you today this week on Friday
every single Friday in the second hour
the Tony Michaels podcast every single
Friday and we also we also if you're
over on the Midas Dutch Network we
broadcast we replay the broadcast on a
minor statue Network so don't forget to
follow us over the Tony Michaels podcast
on YouTube even though we've had a
little bit of YouTube treble here lately
we're back we're bad baby boys we are
some bad boys back baby we just came out
of jail yeah that's true what's up
that's right we're we're YouTube
criminals and we were locked up for
quite some time lock us up on YouTube
the game we got we had some boneheads
here
um
boy
boy are they boneheaded um and this was
a close race I actually thought one of
these was gonna come out front but it
was I gotta tell you when I made the
graphic today for the video I was like
damn this is actually way closer than I
thought it was gonna be Ryan I I really
thought um I really thought one of them
would make their way out front and and
not stop but yeah um
a group of boneheads some [ __ ] bonus
so where should we start should we start
with a judge yeah I think I think we
should start with let's judge judge
judgment yeah judge well I mean if she
if you can consider her a [ __ ] judge
well yeah yeah I mean let's what I find
funny about the situation is that at the
end of the day the people that were also
very critical of her were Trump
appointed judges
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait beautiful wait
wait now you're the criticism that
you're speaking of where did the
criticism appear right so this was if we
go back to where this started right
Trump was like Hey I want to shop this
around to different judges and I'm sure
I am sure he had a list of people to be
like look this is who we brought in we
think we might have a good choice it's
like when people are trying to like when
lawyers are trying to select a journey
like who are they more willing to feel
like sympathetic or be more kind of
objective and judgmental about the the
person that's on on trial so with this
I'm sure they had a list of people and
they're like look we we brought her in
so she kind of owes us a favor I feel
like she'll do us a solid
and they went to her and they said hey
we should actually have these documents
we want you to choose a special Master
for us after you know after Trump had
whined and cried about having this one
in a special Master the deal was like
fine well [ __ ] it whatever okay
she gets uh on the case and she says
actually you you the doj don't have
rights to these documents it's actually
Trump's properties it's kind of weird
kind of weird yeah it doesn't make any
sense in that it does make Trump sense
you know right but I mean it makes sense
in the in the fact that it the only way
for him to really skate criminal charges
here is if he can somehow prove that
these are his not the government right
exactly so she puts out her her legal
opinion and says yeah these documents
these especially these hundred
classified documents the doj should not
actually be able to review any further
and uh it should be you know the
basically ruling in favor of trump
which a lot of people at the time were
like you know what the [ __ ] is going on
and if this gets uh appealed then or if
they try to appeal it it's going to go
in the doj's favor because this is not
how someone should rule
so at that point everyone is talking uh
there is obviously criticism the
criticism that follows especially in the
way that how judge Eileen Cannon uh went
through this was from Trump appointed
judges
which is even which which again like I
said makes us even more beautiful
because it's almost it's almost as good
as the judges that were Trump appointed
that overruled to say or like you know
kind of throughout the election fraud
cases that Giuliani and others brought
forward because they were like oh they
thought they were going to be able you
know no problem go through and say there
was election fraud and those judges were
going to take it but it turns out that
those judges were like ah you know what
look I'm willing to support you only so
far but this [ __ ] [ __ ] is crazy and I
can't do it
and so it's the same situation where
they've appointed these judges because
loyalty and they want them to you know
do what they want they want to be a
follower and then it turns out that
these judges actually [ __ ] turn
around and say that's not how the law
works right well and even even this uh
the dairy the special master that was
appointed because Dairy is a federal
judge which it's kind of awkward to have
a sp apparently to have a special master
who is a sitting federal judge that
doesn't happen a lot but the reason why
it happened in this situation is because
I believe the Trump team thought that
this guy was corrupt because he was part
of the fisa court that that issued the
warrant uh for the wiretaps on Carter
page so like oh this guy is totally
corruptable which if you go back and
look at the Carter page fisa warrant
there wasn't corruption yeah in that it
was a mistake but it wasn't corruption
on the fisa courts part right so I don't
understand if that was their logic that
this judge Deary was somehow corruptible
cool but it almost feels like because in
their little where they were nominating
a recommending special Masters they had
one other but this one was Trump's
appointment they wanted Deary but they
had two choices and they made him one of
the choices but they called him a
retired and one that retired in so many
words but they almost thought that he
was retired he wasn't sitting on a
current federal bench right so it's
almost they thought like okay he's
corruptable and he's retired so he won't
be he won't be tied to any kind of you
know oath or commitment to the current
court or something I don't know but he's
in the he's in the eastern district
of New York right he's a sitting judge a
sitting federal judge and it is it's not
unheard of but it is kind of weird that
a sitting federal judge is a special
Master but they have special legal
things where they can do that and so
they did it because the doj's like oh
you want Deary oh you [ __ ] up because
doj's like this guy is a no-nonsense
judge yeah he follows he literally he's
not he was nominated under Ronald Reagan
yeah he was confirmed under Ronald
Reagan this guy's not just been on the
court for a couple years motherfucker's
been on the court for a long damn time
knows how it works right he's been a
federal judge for quite some time yeah
and he's always been No Nonsense if you
look at this guy's record he's not
really a partisan and and what I mean by
that is he's not really a liberal he's
not a conservative he's just like he's
as benign as uh federal judges you might
want right right like in all rule of law
fairness he's really been right
and why they selected this guy is beyond
me because immediately when he gets to
be the special Master the first question
he asked is the question that this
[ __ ] bonehead Cannon should have
asked right and he totally [ __ ] her you
know I don't know if she's gonna show up
on the Apple guy but she totally got
cocked here and the reason why is
because he says hey you're claiming As
Trump and his legal team you're claiming
that you Declassified these documents
right I want to see the proof where you
declare which it doesn't matter and he
knows it doesn't matter but he knows
that that one question alone
totally smashes up their entire [ __ ]
argument over this whole thing because
they keep saying I Declassified them as
if that exalts him of any crime of
taking the [ __ ] stealing the documents
harboring them not securing them and
obstructing justice to get them back
like not the D the classification of
these documents regardless of what you
think actually happens or how it gets
Declassified it doesn't make a
difference one iota and that's what the
judge Deary understands and he's like
hey your main argument here is [ __ ]
I get that but I want to see proof that
you even can make this argument because
they actually have to have evidence to
make the argument
and I was gonna say that he he really
did come forward and was like look step
up or shut up right that was the way
that they looked because he was like
look you claim that you Declassified
these documents fine okay whatever
if you did so show me the proof which is
the same thing that everyone has said
which is like okay look you claim to
have waved your hands and thought it or
whatever that you declassify these
things but we need some sort of receipts
a piece of paper some other agency that
approved it something to show us that
you actually Declassified not some
[ __ ] cash Patel interview on Fox News
well but that's the thing but that's the
thing is they they walked they moved the
goal post like they always do because
cash Patel came out and he said I was
standing in the room when he did it and
now yesterday or well the day before
yesterday he goes on Sean handed it and
he that's not what he says at all he
doesn't say I stood over the boxes and
declared them Declassified he says well
I thought it so that must Beth what it
is if right exactly literally they are
even moving the goal posts because
here's the thing folks they know they're
[ __ ] there is no evidence cash Patel
when he tells you that [ __ ] on some
interview somewhere and he noticed cash
Patel hasn't been in the news here
lately nope because he's completely I'm
sure he uh he might have gotten I don't
know like a subpoena or something right
from the doj to be like hey so you said
this stuff yeah yeah talk a little bit
so you were there when he was doing this
it's kind of funny how you would say out
in public that you were there when he
was committing crime really funny how
cash Patel would do that the other thing
too here that I think people are missing
from the the interview that I think
Canon [ __ ] totally dropped the ball
on is what the documents are what they
are folks I'm just I'm just speculating
here and I'm only using the Cheeto dust
Mobsters projection to to
um to actually do the speculation but
it's pretty easy to read him he's
predictably unpredictable my guess is
almost every single document that he
stole that has especially human assets
on it
um it is intelligence that was collected
on him it has his name on the documents
it's intelligence that was elected by
our intelligence to see about him we
know that there was Intelligence
collected on we know he colluded we know
he tried to obstruct an investigation in
the Russian collusion and our government
on the 2016 election we know that we
know they invited Russians to the Trump
Tower we know all of this and I would
almost bet of my last dollar is that
those documents most of the documents he
stoled are Intelligence on himself yeah
because he's not interested in anything
else but himself anyway so why would he
makes sense name and he's like that mine
mine mine well and that's the other
reason why he thinks it's his right
don't you think well I think 100 I think
the other thing too is like if my hands
are on it it's mine which is like that's
not how that works also like again there
is a process and when when he goes on
Sean Hannity and his [ __ ] fake gold
room and says I thought it therefore it
is and he says oh well actually there's
no real process to it that is not at all
true there is is a process you can as a
I mean a president can unilaterally
declassify things but there's a process
that goes in where the agency that
classify them says hey yes we can
declassify it there is a process you
have to get the people involved who who
made the choice to say actually the
public cannot know this right now well
and and to be fair a president can
actually override that but again it's
not just the thought in your brain right
there would be some sort of back and
forth It's called government I don't
know it's called crazy I don't know
crazy it's kind of weird but it's one of
those things that yeah I know it's one
of those things again that it's like if
you in fact did it then you should have
no problem no problem whatsoever to
prove that you did it you've got an
email you've got a letter you got a
phone call you got a video you got a
voice recording you have something
something besides your dumb ass fat
orange [ __ ] brain right it's not that
because that's not a real thing so
either you did it and you've got
evidence for it or you didn't do it and
you're trying to make up and lie about
you did do it right well I'm sure we're
going to get into more of this and I
want to give you my opinion on what they
would do if Jill Biden said this type of
[ __ ] so remind me when we get to this
this other bonehead yeah yeah because I
know we're gonna talk about that but
let's talk about Ron Ron DeSantis Rhonda
Santos can go [ __ ] himself you know what
I mean Ron human trafficking to Santas
ha
oh this gay and I know I know this kind
of sinks into you uh really deep Gabe
because your family came here
um from Mexico to seek a better life in
America and your dad worked his ass off
to do that and you're here as an
American citizen because of that yeah um
and for them to treat these human beings
like just pieces of meat I know makes
you infuriated yeah um it is because
it's personal to you yeah I mean like I
know how hard my dad worked and how much
that he sacrificed to provide for our
family and how much that he wanted us my
brother and myself to have a better life
and so when I see someone like Ron
DeSantis or Greg Abbott just goes Willy
ah yeah well you know I throw him on a
plane I shoot him up to Martha's
Vineyard or I shoot him over to you know
uh VP Harris's house or shoot him up to
Delaware to go see you know President
Biden that type of stuff where it's like
they aren't they aren't humans they're
not treated like humans they're treated
like objects and it's disgusting
because they give no actual uh care as a
fellow human would toward another human
they don't actually follow the Christian
values they don't actually say hey look
maybe we should treat these people that
are seeking Asylum and refuge and a
better life in this country an
opportunity instead of lying to them
giving them some BS pamphlet lying about
this Perla which I'm sure is Christina
Pusha which is kind of the right-hand
person the director of of Ron DeSantis
and that also seems like the the the the
this target for the pro the criminal
probe that's happening and so like it's
not just them and so right now I'm I'm
happy to see that like not only is our
investigation from Javier Salazar in San
Antonio of Bexar County not only are we
seeing a class action lawsuit from the
48 migrants that were flown under false
pretenses to Martha's Vineyard but we're
now seeing this moment of like there are
consequences for the actions that you
take there are consequences for you
being a shitty awful garbage human being
and not respecting someone else who is
trying to seek the thing that you
promise that is something that you get
in this country which is you get the
family you get the house you get this
you get that but if someone doesn't look
white you know they're brown they're
black whatever they are you don't get
the same rights you don't get the same
opportunities you don't get the same
amount of respect and freedom and
liberty that we've declared in the
Constitution that you [ __ ] rile
yourselves up as [ __ ] Patriots but
really you're all just a bunch of
[ __ ] fake treats you're not real you
don't actually care about people you are
hypocrites you don't follow the
Constitution you don't respect Law and
Order despite that you say oh we're the
party of Law and Order you don't
actually care for the the to back the
blue like we saw that on January 6th
like this is a party that is
anti-American it is anti-life it is just
anti-human rights and at the end of the
day that is what the Republican party is
so when you see Ron DeSantis ship
someone over from Texas
on a plane to Martha's Vineyard because
ah you know what we're gonna [ __ ] own
the libs that is a terrible thing to do
that is a terrible human and as a
terrible party that stands behind him
and supports like [ __ ] Ted Cruz and
these other [ __ ] cups well because
today is there a commitment to Cruelty
and their commitment is to do more of
this stuff and and to treat other human
beings like pieces of meat and
analytical political ponds because let
me tell you something most areas in this
country blue States especially and a lot
of these big metropolitan areas would
welcome these migrants these refugees
who are seeking as I am to come here
they would love for them if if they
could find a way for Greg Abbott and Ron
DeSantis to organize to spend the
federal dollars that they've given and
to make it efficient to get them to
their areas the problem is the reason
why they had to go down to Texas and San
Antonio to coerce these people out of
shelters is because they are seeking
asylum in Texas yeah there's and they
have a federal courthouse there where
they have to appear for their legal
Asylum hearing right and they can't go
to [ __ ] other states they can't go to
other places yet because they have to
get their Asylum done so that they can
actually move right and what these
Republicans these vile cruel pieces of
[ __ ] are doing is coercing these people
out of a situation where they're seeking
legal asylum in this country for for
Refuge to America for the American dream
the American the Liberty that they claim
to love which they only love it for
white Christian Nationals and that's it
um and really honestly if you have the
passion that Gabe has for Ron DeSantis
going and [ __ ] himself show it with a
t-shirt Ronda Santos can go [ __ ] himself
the other the other thing I want to
point out is the fact that like even if
you say you know we've got an
immigration problem and we need to fix
it great fine that's totally a thing
let's actually bring it out to the table
but if you're willing to lie uh you know
uh Hoodwink uh you know bait and switch
which someone and say oh you know again
who are seeking Asylum and have have
actual Court appearances in Texas and
then say get on this flight we'll give
you money we'll give you shelter we'll
take you to this place
nice
miles away thousands of miles away right
from from somewhere that not only are
you thousands of miles or hundreds of
miles from your where your actual home
original home was in these countries
that you were seeking Asylum from so now
you're in a new country and then you say
oh actually we're going to ship you off
to this spot again to own the lips like
it's really crazy the biggest thing the
biggest [ __ ] problem that I have with
this is the fact that innocent innocent
Floridians and Texans they are paying
the price literally right the price
their tax dollars are going in and
paying for the transportation the
illegal transportation of these migrants
who are seeking Asylum as a political
stunt for a campaign right so you've got
some you've got a you've got a governor
in Texas or and you've got a governor in
Florida and they're both trying to see
who can do the worst here like the fact
that you're trying to outdo the other
one to see hey how much shittier can I
be than you
well I mean I mean that's trumpism in in
yeah I mean in a nutshell well you're
100 I mean the Cheeto dust mobster is
went all full q and on over on fraud
social apparently but I guess people are
totally fine with with paying extra
money or having their tax dollars they
could go towards roads infrastructure uh
repairing your community actually going
to the things that you say hey I'm
paying my taxes they should go to the
things that I have
actually a stake in do not say oh you
should take that money and then go pay
for these people to be illegally
transported across state lines did I
mess up here did I get the winner wrong
I think I got the winner wrong here
do I have the wrong winner in there no I
don't know did you do the math because
I'm on the winner right now
I did not know that he won I thought the
other guy won the former guy oh uh yes
he he did did he inch he inched out he
inched out yeah this is my mistake oh my
god this is my mistake folks this is my
mistake folks I thought I really thought
that the Cheeto deaths mobster I really
thought that he won but I see I'm giving
it away I'm giving it away wow and it
was Ron DeSantis we'll come back around
we'll come back we got enough uh Rhonda
santis can go [ __ ] himself energy yeah
for the winner and again if you want to
get some Ronda Santos can go [ __ ]
himself merch go to
store.dtonymichaels.com it's a great
design we made the meme and everyone's
like t-shirts so I made a t-shirt so
there's hoodies coffee cups cut I've
seen a lot of suggestions for fake Gabe
to be nominated as like Alpha cook or
dishonorable mention oh really look if
fake Gabe wants to submit his real photo
yeah absolutely yeah [ __ ] the other
Avatar then I'll take it and I I will I
will consider you make the sound of that
type well let's let's move on to to then
the former guy here I want to I want to
get to this because we're gonna run out
of time here
um
as I was saying before I want to mention
this whole I thinketh and they'd be
Declassified if this whatever this is
this if the president thinks it then
it's a thing here's the thing
can you [ __ ] imagine Gabe if today
Joe Biden's like I'm calling a press
conference and he comes out in front of
the microphone and he says on January
20th 2021 when my hand left the Bible
yeah and I was president at that moment
in time I'm telling you right now
retroactively that at that moment I
thought in my brain
that all all the records yeah that were
Declassified by Donald Trump are
reclassified the way they were before
that means he goes to jail no get out of
jail free card go lock him up get the
[ __ ] handcuffs arrest him and oh by
the way get Donald Trump Jr's laptop and
get Eric Eric Trump's uh diary get it
all get it all from him lock him up lock
them up lock them up can you [ __ ]
imagine oh D just the hemorrhaging on
the right they would lose their [ __ ]
minds because it's not a thing it's Joe
Biden couldn't come out and say that
nonsense right because it isn't real
that's why it's really frustrating when
a bunch of [ __ ] dummies in this
country a bunch of boneheads these Q
Anon cult members believe this nonsense
when this orange Mussolini Jesus says it
what the [ __ ] are you talking about it's
like you know they're this whole like I
Declassified everything
oh you know
that type of logic
doesn't really work when you can't tell
me what the [ __ ] you have in those boxes
right like if you just took a [ __ ] ton
of [ __ ] because it mentioned your name
or it was this classified nuclear
documents or this or that or whatever
right
if you just took and we're like yep
everything in these boxes Declassified
doesn't work that way because you have
to show me and prove that you knew what
you took should have been Declassified
just like if Joe Biden were to say I
classified everything it'd be like well
maybe some of those things were really
Declassified but now you're re-class but
like there's no list there's no order
there's no actual function it's off
chaos and this guy is just believing for
whatever insane reason that if he thinks
it then it becomes reality it's really
you know what if he really thought hard
enough that maybe he would have won the
election I don't know but turns out that
another seven plus million people said
not your thought is pretty [ __ ] so
goodbye right and we don't want a
fascist running our country here's
here's the clip from Hannity it's a
longer clip but there's several things
in this that I want to talk about so
let's watch this clip here because he
says he says a couple of them things
Gabe number one he says uh at Mar-A-Lago
and wherever which means there's other
documents wherever he has other
properties or right other presences or
it has a presence somewhere right and
then he talks about Russia and then he
talks about Russia Russia Russia rush
Russia which and information on him and
the Clinton emails this only tells me
that he's projecting that all the
intelligence that he was trying to
gather up was Intelligence that the
intelligence agency collected on him and
you know which kind of brings up a point
remember when he was saying oh I was
taking this for my library you remember
that my presidential life remember that
was one of their flimsy arguments that
they moved the goal post on yeah he was
taking it so it didn't end up in front
of the the American people 50 60 years
from now and they know yeah this guy
holy [ __ ] this guy was a Trader before
2016. yeah
this guy was a he's been a traitor for a
long time I can't believe Americans
actually supported this Mussolini
Mussolini orange Jesus I cannot believe
it and that's what he's trying that's
why he wants to hide it
this is a great uh steal uh he was
jacked y'all the whole time because he
was really pissed off he's trying to
prevent himself from
[Laughter]
wait wait wait did it
[Music]
that's that's it
I mean again can you can you grab that
can you grab the picture of his new
diaper white yeah go grab it while we're
talking go ahead what were you gonna say
sorry no I was just gonna say I actually
was going to point out oh okay the the
uh dumpy lump that he left in his back
from I guess in his junk in his trunk
yeah like ooh trumpy got back
okay well we were thinking the same
thing let's let's uh let's watch this
clip of Dumb and Dumber talk about how
it doesn't work so let me ask you this
question because I I think this is the
next logical question because the
president of the United States you
unlike say Hillary Clinton in her case a
president has the power to declassify
correct okay you had said on Truth
social a number of times you did
declasses oh yeah okay is there a
process what was your process to do it
doesn't have to be a process as I
understand it you know there's different
people say different things but as I
understand there doesn't have to be if
you're the president of the United
States you can declassify just by saying
it's Declassified even by thinking about
it this is really embarrassing this is
so embarrassing I can't even believe
that these people are like this is my
guy like just in this little this first
30 seconds of this interview it's it's
so stupid it's so dumb and they're like
they're even trying to almost figure out
a way to convince even the dumbest of
the dumb that hey it really is just a
situation where he's so powerful and
he's so you know he's such a great
leader that he can just think it that
other leaders can't do that it's just
him that can do that like this is the
same type of stuff as when they think oh
Joe Biden is the one controlling
inflation and gas prices and this and
that like that it's the same type of
logic it's so [ __ ] asinine it doesn't
make any [ __ ] sense so when you've
got this guy saying oh well yeah there's
no real process as far as I know I just
classified there is a process and I
would hope that if someone's going to
lie about stealing classified documents
from the government and playing this
whole like uh I don't have it I have it
I don't really have it here are some
documents but they're not all the
documents and then oh you guys came into
my house illegally to get the documents
that I told you I didn't have
at the end of the day if you're gonna
lie about this stuff if you're gonna if
you're gonna say oh I actually did
declassify them you better [ __ ] know
the actual process that's involved you
better know like oh well actually this
actually is Declassified or it's a
little bit different in this case
because of XYZ but if you just say yeah
there's actually no process to it I can
declassify whatever I want and if I
think it then everyone else should
[ __ ] know that it's Declassified
again I would hope that if someone's
going to steal these documents and try
to make this argument that they would at
least know some nuances of the actual
process to try to navigate it out other
than no I thought it so it's a thing
so Elgin Charles has it here you sent
him he said
Donald Trump get a BBL
for anyone who doesn't know what a BBL
is I believe it's a Brazilian butt lift
is that what the is that what a BBL is
yeah
I've seen where they take fat out of the
another part of your body and and inject
it into your ass is that the it's I mean
that's the that's the actual person I
mean you know not saying I'm not so you
know crude as I put it but you know what
damn what am I gonna be like oh let's be
back later but uh it's it is Brazilian
butt lift right BBL is Brazilian I've
seen I've seen uh some some bad like
online someone's like don't get a
Brazilian butt lift you know like or
like here's the results and they were
holding yeah so does it does it depend
on your plastic surgeon I would imagine
it's kind of like a mechanic like if you
go get your your engine replaced right
if you have a really shitty mechanic it
may not turn out so great but if you
have a good mechanic you may be able to
do this he or she may be able to do the
job and get the engine done yeah you
know you're paying for quality and
hoping that the mechanic that's doing
the work on your car is actually uh
smart competent yeah yeah competent
actually knows what they're talking
about but yeah it is uh it this one
looks like a really if this is a BBL if
elgin's right here and he did get a BBL
this is his plastic surgeon was way off
the Mark
um because yeah well Elgin also says I
guess he's preparing
for his time in the clink I don't I
don't know if this is like Elgin I don't
know if this is a reference like people
are gonna like this or what but he even
gives an arrow here dude's got a fat ass
anyways yeah my dude's got a fat ass
have you ever seen pictures of him
golfing or or tennis he's got a fat I
mean yeah he's got he's got Big Macs as
far as the eye can see with you know
maybe crazy could be crazy thought here
maybe he's got documents stuffed in his
ass oh maybe you're always walking with
these dogs because he doesn't want him
to search anywhere else that's maybe
where the whatever is he's like at
Mar-A-Lago or my ass whatever like in my
diaper right exactly like the idea that
the idea he's like yeah or whatever like
I don't know it could be like wherever
uh and you know meanwhile like documents
are probably I made a joke about how he
you know maybe he had a stuff in his
jacket but then I really looked at the
video later and I was like could be
maybe he's got [ __ ] stuffed in his pants
like I don't know actual [ __ ] but he's
got [ __ ] stuffed in his pants that are
actual documents this seems to be
growing look at that it's very it's
protective
God damn road there I know I well and
you know it's I I stopped carrying my
wallet my back pocket because you'd
always do the you know you did
it's bad for your hip right right fine
but so maybe at first you think this but
you're like no that wallet would be the
size of an Oldsmobile to get your ass to
go up like that I mean it was it was
when I when I see this I immediately go
to the right Kindergarten Cop with
Arnold Schwarzenegger right and he's
like oh I've got a my you know I got a
headache right and the kid's like well
maybe it's a tumor and he's like it's
not a tumor and that is what I imagine
here it's not a BBL like you've got this
junk and you got this dump truck
full of documents and and trying here is
like oh what's going on with your back
maybe uh he's like I don't know maybe
it's a tumor he's like it's not a tumor
it's not a tumor it's not a tumor it's
like an Arnold Schwarzenegger uh Donald
Trump there uh but the idea that he's
got this [ __ ] fat ass
right thick with three K's
uh that is it looks like it looks like
the uh uh Gabe we got some breaking news
here on bone out of the week because we
got an alpha cook I don't mean to switch
gear so fast yeah yeah but it looks like
people are doing this um they're having
a press conference here who is
explaining the bone and or the alpha
cuck is of the week There's Jr gay go
ahead J.R Majewski yeah some people
might know him as the man I sent you a
couple links for photos he made his his
self known by creating a huge Trump
Banner on his lawn he painted his whole
lawn as a trump flag right and it was
all over social media it was all all
over right it was a really shitty paint
job too I made fun of it on an old
sketch I did I think we talked about it
a couple times on the show because he
was in insurrectionist too right exactly
so not only is he an insurrectionist he
was there at the Capitol storming he
also is a q Anon believer he believes
that January 6 was actually FBI go
figure uh and now he's running for uh
Ohio's uh Congressional Ninth District
is this the guy who had the video where
he just like had the gun and he was in
the warehouse and that sort of [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's the guy oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh I'm a [ __ ] tough yeah I got
my
guns [ __ ] love their guns and
shooting and overcompensating for the
things that they lack whether it's
intelligence or down there either head
it's pretty wait wait you mean down
there like in the front are like Donald
Trump in the back where he's trying to
stuff and get the beat I think it's I
think it's in the front but okay he's
also pretty large so he might have some
classified documents in his trunk as
well so a lot of mushroom size stuff
going on yeah yeah very small very small
heads gotcha so when I
this guy you know is insurrectionist Q
Anon believer but the reason
that and he was at he was at the O he
was at the Youngstown Ohio rally uh this
past weekend coming up there and talking
about who he is and what he represents
all the [ __ ] but the reason that he's in
the news now it's because of Stolen
Valor oh you're telling me you're
telling me that these megalodites uh
have the have went in stovallor yeah I I
now I remember this now I remember this
so he the reason it became a big thing
is because the RNC was helping it was
like 900 000 or so dollars that they
were pushing into yeah almost a million
bucks right yeah into the because they
really thought they could get him to win
yeah they were they were funding his uh
marketing commercials everything as the
race leads up to the midterms the
problem is that when this [ __ ] came out
that oh it turns out that he lied about
missing his grandmother's funeral and
serving in Iraq he lied about his actual
time in Afghanistan he lied about
actually having this position as a
member of the military this came out and
the RNC was like oh [ __ ] and they pulled
the rug right from under him they took
it
took all the funding and they're like
dude you're on your own we cannot
support you because you lied
about where you served what you served
where you were what you did like all of
these things and again go figure that
it's a it's a trump-loving human
insurrectionist that says oh actually uh
I served in the military and I did these
things when it actually wasn't he didn't
serve where he said he was he wasn't in
Afghanistan he wasn't there he was I
think he was in Qatar uh which is
thousands of miles away yes that was the
story this morning and they they pulled
the funding here the bonehead is the
alpha cook here he is cucking himself
this is a clip from a press conference
this morning where he's trying to
explain this away and again you see his
sign back here Majewski America First
veteran for congress listened to his
Donald Trump style excuse and I think
Donald Trump should just think this and
get this out in the open listen to his
excuse hero why these lies aren't actual
lies
the inquiry States
we show one deployment to Qatar from May
2002 to November 2002.
what he did meaning me
or where he may have went from that
location we do not have visibility on
in fact the orders and the military
records that I've been able to
obtain from my personal files shows that
all of my deployments are listed as
classified
foreign
could not actually produce these
documents because when they were
questioned they said yeah he was in
Qatar and this is when he was there
but the idea that he goes well look
nobody knew where I was because they
[ __ ] secret Ops that was a [ __ ]
Navy SEAL I was the guy who killed Osama
Bin Laden [ __ ] that is this guy
right here um he's going to climacy
classified because I was working on top
secret [ __ ] dog right that is the guy
that this is this is the 100 you know
what you know what I wonder if we could
get Joe Biden to just think that these
records should be Declassified and then
bam we can fix this we could fix this
Majewski problem and get this out in the
open because they want transparency baby
that's what they want they want
transparency they want freedom they want
Liberty so Joe Biden I'm calling on the
president United States Joe Biden to
think just to have the thought that
these records that Majewski is claiming
are classified so we know the truth
about him because we all want to know
he's the Great American Patriot that he
claims to be Joe Biden please think it
that way we know it this yeah please
declassify those military records to
prove that Majewski actually isn't this
crazy spy covert classified Soldier
that's out running Gun and shooting
killing all that [ __ ] this guy's a
[ __ ] cuck and that's why I put
him on Alpha cut this week for his
Stolen Valor for his line about serving
in the military and what he did and then
you know the the trumpy thing that he's
doing here is digging an even deeper
hole by going out and saying this
nonsense and creating I mean he's trying
to salvage his campaign he's like hey
you can't prove I didn't do this if the
documents don't actually exist yeah
they're classified I guarantee someone
from the Air Force is now going to come
out and be like nope we do have the
document I'm waiting for the reporter
I'm waiting for the reporter to ask Joe
Biden to declassify these things just
think it tell us out loud just say it
out loud and boom it's true I'm waiting
for a moment where he could tweet it he
could tweet it Gabe he could he could
[ __ ] tweet it I'm just saying I I
know he still got his Twitter account he
could tweet that these records are
Declassified and boom it will be be done
he doesn't even have to think it he can
just tweet it tweet it tweet us and it
Beth right oh my god well the other
thing I just want to point out is like
you know
I feel kind of bad for people who have
to go through the whole like uh Stolen
Valor routine right like I served and I
was a military vet or whatever I did
this or I was here and lie about that to
like feel some sort of
uh like relevance right he served in the
military why would he lie about it sir
yeah exactly it's honorable to serve in
the military regardless of where they
assigned you to be but to lie about
those things as right as a person
running
for a seat as a politician well I mean
we see how that turns out with like
Madison Gotham we see how that turns out
yeah yeah and and even and even uh
several others like like Tom Cotton he's
he's he's participating in stolen vary
like exaggerating his military service
it's ridiculous speaking of a ridiculous
exaggerations the dishonorable mentioned
this morning is Kevin McCarthy because I
want to let you folks know that the
Republicans release their commitment to
cruelly for America this morning
um Gabe there wasn't a lot of people
watching this thing I think most the
people that were watching were people
who were going to do what we're doing
which is [ __ ] knocking on it trying
to give people how to politicize this
thing literally uh they basically the
tenements of this thing is hey we want
white Christian
domestic terrorist nationalists to not
have Law and Order everyone else brown
black people liberals we want them to
have Law and Order and we want Cops to
go take after them I mean unless the
cops come after us white Christian
nationalists then we'll beat him with
flagpoles at the Capitol yeah but also
also they want to get rid of Education
they don't want your children to have
education and the best part is they're
going to undo everything that Joe Biden
did including the infrastructure that
they go out and they get big checks to
and they're bragging about and lowering
drug prices in the inflation reduction
act
um and they're bitching about high gas
prices as they go down which doesn't
make sense
I really I don't think that Kevin
McCarthy
is doing himself much good even if Newt
Gingrich tweets about how this is the
con new contract for America when it's
not even resembling close to the
contract for America it's only cruelty
on Americans they want they want America
where they have the leg up where they
there's no equality there's no equity
it's only a nation for white Christian
nationalists and the domestic Maga
terrorists right that they are and
remember what happened this week
specifically talking about those
domestic terrorists from January 6th
they had the people the 1776 restoration
movement flooded the uh the VA suicide
hotline
so to demand that they release the
January 6 protesters like this is the
this is these these are people that say
oh Patriots but serve and we're in the
military and all this [ __ ] like
they want to flood the line that is a
resource to to Veterans who are who are
dealing with suicide or thoughts of
suicide and flood them so those people
can't get the resources because they
want a [ __ ] [ __ ] and moan about how
some person that stormed the capital and
broke the law and threatened to hang the
vice president is now serving time or is
in is in uh jail waiting for their court
appearance this is the same group of
people that want to do this to the
people that we so
gratefully thank and say thank you for
the service but within the same breath
we'll say you know you can go [ __ ]
yourself I don't really care about you
well here's Elise stefanik and Kevin
McCarthy throwing it around the idea
that hey if you're a domestic terrorist
we're gonna get you off the watch list
because you're one of us because they
know we know they they all see
themselves as domestic terrorists they
said at the Nazi rally down in Texas uh
at the CPAC meeting let's listen to
Elise stefanik and Kevin McCarthy say
how they're gonna get domestic
terrorists off the watch list priority
for our education Committee in the next
Congress
so I hope when
I'll make this personal pledge I don't
know that if it happened but any parent
that got put on the terrorist watch list
by the do priority he says he goes on to
say that he's going to take them off the
watch list any domestic terrorist who is
threatening elected officials I'm gonna
make sure to get you off the watch list
because we don't want punishment for
white Christian National Domestic
terrorists we just don't want that in
this America and Trump's America we want
to make sure white people can do
whatever they want commit whatever
violence they can try to even overthrow
elections they can even try to overthrow
elections Gabe you know what you know
that that that uh threatening people
their lives was totally cool under the
Constitution I didn't know that Tony I
didn't know that those that we were well
accused imprisoning these people that
were that were making death threats Cape
it's the white Constitution it's the one
that white people have to follow white
Christian Nationals have a different
Constitution it's a different one than
what other speaking of white people
going after and denigrating
migrants brown people as he as as just
pieces of meat we go back to the winter
Ron DeSantis here
um again there's not enough Gabe you
could probably do a four-hour uh rant on
this oh yeah just from your experience
of being the reason why you're here in
this country is because your dad came
here really honestly almost everyone
watching here that's in America I'm here
my family came in the late 19th century
as migrants to this country yeah they
crossed over the border and this country
welcomed the migrants to this country
they worked hard they had shitty jobs
they had a sh they had they had shitty
living conditions even then because they
were broken poor but they knew Coming to
America there was opportunity for
Liberty and freedom and equality and
equity
and that's what they strive for and
that's what they were pushing for they
really truly believe that that's why all
of us are [ __ ] here in the first one
unless you have native blood and you are
native then right we stole it from you
right we still I mean like the the way
that Republicans look at this is like
they go they get invited to play a game
they take the ball and they say no one
can play the game anymore that's what
this is they got invited to play which
is oh we were migrants and we came to
this country seeking a better life right
we see the Statue of Liberty we see
these things great boom Beacon of Hope
and as soon as we get here and we make
our lives better because that is what
this country is all about
then they say ah you know what actually
we don't need any more people that don't
look like us right there's too many
you're getting to be to where you're
you're really happy to to uh like the
light-skinned area right a little dark
and and that is what they say when
they're unhappy with the fact that the
white representation of their caucus
whatever is actually becoming diverse
and becoming the Melting Pot that
America is and should be but they feel
threatened for whatever either the
opportunities the talent the skill the
intelligence
just the beauty of people who come that
aren't looking white right like there's
they feel threatened by just the
presence of someone who doesn't look
like them who isn't mediocre who isn't
just average they feel threatened by
these people and the immediate reaction
they have is nope no no you can't come
you can't no you can't be here because
that's not fair that's not that's not
fair that's not fair to me because
you're threatening me I mean that's what
it is really well it's cruelty it's
cruelty and it's their commitment to
Cruelty and this guy's commitment to
Cruelty because we know he's a fascist
down in Florida and he's laying out a
blueprint right for a fascist state of
America Florida you have a large
population that literally came from Cuba
right like that is they're migrants and
then you're gonna say you know what's
funny too about these these these
Venezuelans that they they coerced on a
plane and sent to Martha's Vineyard do
you know what type of government they
were actually leaving persecution from
do you know it wasn't it wasn't a
fascist government it's the one one that
they always taught they always say what
they call us
um what do they call us this libtards
they call us kamiyu Kami coming in
communist oh yes they come from a a
communist government where they're
they're seeking Refuge from persecution
in the communist government and they
can't even they can't even pluck their
head out of their ass long enough to
figure out that oh these act these
people are actually gonna be against the
lip the Communist here and the reason
why they're not is because that's not
how it works that's not what it is
because there's only one commitment to
cruelty in this in this country and it's
the Republican party it's Donald Trump
Ron DeSantis and Kevin McCarthy and
let's do this
let's give the winner his due here Ron
DeSantis bonehead of the week folks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] that bone end of the week that's
what I say Rhonda Santos [ __ ] you you
can go [ __ ] yourself speaking of that
and go to go to store.dtonymichaels.com
and get your Rhonda santus can go [ __ ]
himself merch t-shirts hoodies coffee
mugs wear it loudly and proudly at Ronda
santis can go [ __ ] himself and I think
that's Kim so he can go [ __ ] himself
well I think that's a great a Great
Rally crime because really with this
cruelty this commitment to Cruelty on
America that the Republicans are
releasing today it's more the same it's
more the brown people aren't Real
Americans we'll ship them wherever we
want them we'll treat them as meat
they're not really they're not they're
here illegally even though they're here
legally seeking Asylum from Refuge from
a communist country it really is um it's
weird that we have to explain this to
people but folks we do have to lean into
democracy we do have to do that and how
you can do that is watch the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central on YouTube Twitter and twitch
we're back on YouTube folks and we're
back off our band so go follow the
Johnny Michaels podcast and if you're on
the Midas touch Network right now
watching the replay of bone of the week
subscribe to minus touch but also go
over to the Tony Michaels podcast and
download every single episode of the
podcast at Apple Spotify Google and
follow us on the Tweety tweets and the
trendy trends at Tony Michaels pod
that's where you vote for bone end of
the week every single week you decide
you vote we break it down every single
Friday on the Tony Michaels podcast and
the replay on Midas Dodge Network right
here on the tubes of you it's been a
great week what a bunch of news they
really are showing their true colors
it's a lead up into this election so
lean into it engage in your democracy if
you're if you're on the live version
here stick around we have a few
announcements right after the song
thanks for joining boned of the week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
there is no shortage of boneheads this
week like you had to list like 10 people
like which ones I know and here's the
thing some of these [ __ ] showed
up late last night yeah I know I know
well we were we were really worried
about the pole because we wanted to get
it on YouTube right yeah because we we
we're still working through the band
last night we weren't sure I even tried
to contact YouTube yesterday to find out
exactly when it would happen because I
wanted to get all the episodes on
YouTube but it wouldn't even let me like
load them so I couldn't even make them
like it wouldn't let me load anything so
I had to wait till that moment so last
night when we finally got the ban off I
was like loading each episode typing it
out yeah I was scheduling it I went to
bed my time Pacific I was like after
sometime like after 12 30 12 yeah maybe
later than that and I saw like a video
was uploaded 21 minutes prior and I was
like oh man Tony's
um yeah I'm I was I was loading videos
like crazy I was taking videos and and
actually tomorrow I think we're gonna
schedule
because we have the Jeff Timmer
interview in and of itself and then we
have the Michael Cohen interview which
is really great he talks about the golf
course and the lawyers and he talks
about um the sdny and all the stuff
that's going on uh which he's had a lot
of insight the last few days so I think
we'll make that public tomorrow so go
and maybe even yeah we'll do that
tomorrow we'll we'll make those
available tomorrow I wasn't able to make
them available because they they put the
ban on us right before I could post them
up
um and it just I was like [ __ ] because
we wanted to we usually try to post some
of those interviews on Saturday we used
to do a best of but now we're just
posting Clips yeah so you guys kind of
get them as they come we don't wait
until the best of but we wanted to post
those on Saturday but they [ __ ]
banned us Thursday night last week yeah
so we're back on YouTube we're back on
the tubes of you so and but again you
gotta go to Tony michaels.live go to
Tony Michaels dot live anytime the feed
is down or you you're like where the
hell is the [ __ ] show did they quit
we did not quit we are not gonna quit go
to Tony Michaels dot live you can find
us there and really honestly if you
click the little sandwich icon you can
find all the links to all of our
platforms Facebook Twitter twitch so
just go go to tonymichaels.live you can
also find all of the merch there the
[ __ ] hats people asking about that
yesterday the Rhonda santis merch go
[ __ ] himself you can find that there the
doubt me merch as well
um you can find that in the merch store
Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ] himself and
then one of the biggest favorites right
now is the dark Brandon Merch this stuff
is flying off the shelves people love
this this exclusive Tony Michaels
podcast design
store.thetonymichaels.com or again just
go to just go to Tony Michaels dot live
and you can find the merch stores there
at the sandwich icon go to where it all
is Gabe another cool thing and I know
we're running over time here yeah I
wanted to get bony of the week one more
thing we're gonna have some sponsors
here soon we're really looking into some
sponsors I know a lot of people are pet
owners out there so we're trying to find
some some sponsors that that will help
out your pets with their treats and
their toys so give us give us some
suggestions if you can of what sponsors
you'd like to see because we're trying
to find stuff that appeals to a broad
audience um and we don't we want it to
be about you guys and you guys to get
some products that and bring some
products to you that you would love and
enjoy and that way you guys can support
us support The Advertiser and get great
products so so give us some suggestions
what do you want to see as sponsors
because we're going to be looking for
sponsors very very soon we got several
in the works that we're talking to we
want to make sure those products are
great for you guys it's great for the
audience because we want you to enjoy
them and we want you to enjoy the
sponsorship and not only that we want
you to support our sponsors because they
help support the show so it's very
support very important and I also want
to thank everyone through this band that
you guys have supported the show not
just monetarily because you have done
that you can you you guys have supported
pro-democracy speech you supported the
the Tony Michaels podcast and again you
you can go to tonymichaels.live to give
us support there or you can go to
support.tonymichaels dot or Tony
michaelspod.com but go to
tonymichaels.live the tip jar is right
there at the top
um you can leave them a one-time tip or
a monthly tip you can set it up to do it
monthly and we appreciate that but Gabe
the support that we've seen in the
comments and the retweets people
downloading a whole nother app just to
come watch the show has been really
impressive and I I I know that our
message rings cathartically for so many
people and how we do this and we try to
bring you an entertaining show to shed
daylight on what these idiots are trying
to do and how they're trying to take our
democracy away and what you can do to
lean into it and keep your democracy in
your way of life but boy Gabe the
support that our audiences should what a
great what a great audience so we good
incredibly incredibly grateful for
everyone who who has uh
watched you know whether you're you're
real or you're you know a fake troll or
whatever you might be but yeah we like
the haters here we love the hate
Watchers but yeah we I truly I truly do
appreciate the the amount of love and
attention that you guys give us
um because you know we couldn't do it
without you yeah I mean if if you guys
weren't watching we couldn't do this
this is the only way we do this is with
you guys right you guys are are the
backbone of this show
um we're you're the reason why we do
this every single morning you're the
reason why Gabe gets up two hours early
to make a thumbnail to figure out what
that's gonna be to make the bonehead of
the week all the graphics all the
graphics that you see I mean we we do we
both work hard here to bring this show
to you guys and the reason why is
because you guys are here every single
day and what's crazy last night when I
was posting this stuff scheduling it and
it was going out like one in the morning
three in the morning four in the morning
is what I kind of scheduled it for so it
so all those episodes you might have
been asleep and you had already done it
well I was just I was scheduling it out
but I I stayed up to try to schedule it
because I had to load it all in but but
here's the thing when when those were
scheduling the load I was trying to get
them all out before this morning so
everyone at least had a chance to catch
up and know that oh here's all the
episodes but as these things this
morning when I got up the comments were
like hey you're back yay you're back on
YouTube thank God you're back on YouTube
and this was late at night early in the
morning when you when you guys were
leaving these garments it means so much
to us it really does and we really do
love you guys so so please keep showing
your support download every single
episode on your favorite directory leave
us a leave us a great review there while
you're subscribing subscribe and and
follow us on all Platforms in case we do
get banned um because my [ __ ] ass is
likely to get banned somewhere at some
point it's just the way it is so follow
us on all platforms and and we
appreciate all the support you give
regardless if it's a little bit of merch
you guys buy you guys love the merch the
merch whether you give a tip uh every
once in a while or on a monthly basis us
we appreciate you we appreciate the mods
we have the greatest moderators MJ Robin
and Margie the greatest moderators on
Earth give the show them some love uh we
just we just couldn't ask for a better
situation game at the Tony Michaels
podcast we couldn't and and it's been no
apparent than through this band and
really honestly it was disappointing had
the van but I I feel great that the band
happened because it just gave me a
satisfaction to know that what we're
doing means a lot to people and without
you guys we wouldn't be able to do what
we do we would not we would just be
talking into the abyss but you guys you
guys support us you listen and we love
having your and we love that you guys
chat back and forth in all these chat
rooms it's fantastic next week next week
is going to be a big week we are coming
back season two the series the season
premiere of season two I don't know how
many they'll end up doing for January
6th but we're coming back we've had some
very interesting and fruitful
development yeah Genie Thomas apparently
he's gonna now I don't know if she'll
sit in the chair before then because
it's supposedly not on the road there's
gonna be a private one they're trying to
negotiate she's trying to get out of a
criminal liability or I believe
um because one of the one of the
defendants of January 6 who actually
testified in public he actually didn't
get a prison sentence so a lot of these
people are going to run to the table to
try to make sure they show cooperation
with January 6th so a federal judge
doesn't give him a prison sentence I
believe but next week Wednesday the 28th
it is scheduled to be at our air time so
remember next week the Tony Michaels
podcast will be the broadcast of the
January 6th select hearing like Gabe
said season two of treason Hunters
starts up next Wednesday and we will be
here at our normal time broadcasting for
that hearing so don't miss that and have
a great weekend have a great weekend get
a lot of rest you're gonna need it for
next week there's gonna be a ton of news
there's going to be a ton of Leaning
into the market next week I promise you
that so have a safe great weekend until
Monday same time same place unless we
get banned St times same place Surf's Up
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon